[Applaudissements]
alors vous allez vous avez des
casquettes
vous avez des bombes allons-y on va
aller taguer sur l'image de des buts
venait avec nouvelle avec nous donne
avec nous vous attend chez les amis
comptant moins sûr attention patrick
donc et françois et ben on va faire
comme dans le film ils sont douze ans
d'axa sort demain 12 ans d'âge en bien
sûr sur vos écrans pour aller le voir on
va tagué la façade de davy toi je te je
propose c'est qu'on que ce que vous
taguer bachelot très bonne puisque
roselyne bachelot et dans le grand huit
et vous vous voulez tagué quoi plus
thomas gamer guy lagache à poil guy
lagache una faro navarro nique les
experts vendredi que les experts
et moi je vais tagués tiens je vais
tailler un truc je vais était bien sûr
[Rires]
bachelot alors ça va on le boit vous
voulez vous les nôtres bombe
c'est magnifique
les experts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais pu faire dans ce métier la gac
ah merde là d'achat toile voilà bah
ouais j'ai pris le noir voilà ça le fait
bien bachelot tpr et ben voilà eh ben
c'est fait preuve les françois berléand
ya quatre ça comme si c'était une grande
oeuvre la réforme
combien de morts et ben voila patrick
chesnais et reçoit bien leurs actes avec
l'eau je vous avais pas qu'il faut
nettoyer notre monsieur robert si on les
retrouve demain à tous de 12 ans d'âge
patrick chesnais et pro sommes vernis en
bastide un véritable coup ce soir merci
à toute l'équipe de touche pas à mon
pote merci à vous